[Music]
president Trump has delayed his fake
news awards until a week from Wednesday
but what that doesn't mean we don't have
to wait we're gonna hand out our own
media Awards tonight and these are just
from the last two days we're gonna
recognize the work of such luminaries
Carl Bernstein and Mika Brzezinski but
our first award for quote lack of
impartiality goes to an entire network
NBC NBC called Oprah Winfrey our future
president in a tweet last night on its
official account then it took 14 hours
to take the tweet down then NBC blames
some mysterious third party for posting
the tweet yeah we wouldn't want to get
the impression the peacock Network is
rooting against President Trump or
anything so let's bring in Fox News host
of media buzz Howard Kurtz in our
Washington studio so Howard this is like
blaming the intern except they're
blaming a third party I don't even know
what that means what's a third party I
think we need a special prosecutor a
third party is look this was like a
parody of a left-wing organization
particularly the our president part and
the thing about it is you know what this
suggests to me is the 14 hour delay
either the NBC executives were up all
night partying after the Golden Globes
or two out of it to do anything until
noon yeah or they didn't realize it was
anything wrong with the president Oprah
treat until they started getting some
criticism in the press Jesse well
they've been getting a lot of bad press
I think the NBC franchise said that the
Trump tax cut wasn't going to help
workers and then NBC after the Trump tax
cut pass started giving out all thousand
dollar bonus checks to their workers for
Christmas so they haven't had a great
track record over there at NBC but you
know what that's who they are and I
think they're just in it for the money
and the ratings let's get to like
everybody else until of course not of
course that we don't care about the
ratings at all let's get to our next
award remember Carl Bernstein he's the
other Watergate reporter the one whose
career took a little bit of a different
turn than Bob Woodward's but some people
still apparently
want to hear what he has to say and
here's what he he's why he wins our
words have no meaning award roll it
yes we're in a real constitutional
crisis in an unprecedented place how do
we deal with this are we in a
constitutional crisis
speaker Ryan leader McConnell we need to
keep our heads down and just keep going
after the story and stay calm about it
and recognize we are in a constitutional
crisis and we have a special
responsibility anger did you get that
there's a constitutional crisis I kind
of was getting that impression look Carl
Bernstein attacks President Trump just
about every day or every week I mean
he's called him a liar he's called him
worse than Nixon he's talked about the
[ __ ] presidency and you know he gets
a lot of attention because there's a
sort of the Watergate or about what he
says although and he actually worked on
the original story about the unverified
Russian dossier the thing is you know to
compare even in the worst possible
interpretation to compare their
allegations against President Trump and
his associates in the Russia case to the
scandal that made Bernstein famous is
just a ludicrous stretch okay and if
everything is a constitutional crisis
then nothing is I think that's the
fourth or fifth reference that he used I
think there was the the Muller firing
was a constitutional crisis a tweet was
a constitutional crisis now the 25th
amendment we're going to look at a
constitutional crisis we got it
Karl we got it all right and last but
not least the lack of self awareness
award goes to MSNBC's Mika Brzezinski it
doesn't seem to realize that her friends
attitudes may just reveal something
about her I had some friends that went
to Paris over the holiday and they said
they were this really Harris Texas right
Harris France
Oh Paris France and they said they were
just this really embarrassed to be
Americans he said it was it was the
first time that it was sort of chilling
that they didn't even want to share
where they were from okay well I don't
think any Americans should be
embarrassed in Paris because if it
wasn't for America they'd all be
speaking German
going for the work playing the world war
two card look what I play that as much
as possible
Mika comes from a Democratic family he
does hang out with people who consider
Donald Trump an embarrassment
she said much harsher things about him
on Morning Joe but it does come after a
period of time when she and Joe
Scarborough had a very bitter
falling-out with President Trump with
whom they had been friendly for years
and in fairness President Trump has
personally attacked Mika Brzezinski low
IQ and all of that on Twitter so I don't
think there's any question that she is
sharing our opinions and I don't think
you're shocked that she hangs out with
people who don't hold Donald J Trump in
the highest regard yes it does showcase
the kind of elitism and I like Mika I
think she's talented and I've watched
that show a few times and she's
interesting and she looks like fun but
too you know to talk about your friends
that are vacationing in Paris and
they're ashamed to be Americans I just
don't know about the rest of the
American audience when they see her
talking like that if they really even
care to relate I don't think they do
it's like the foreign correspondent say
I just interviewed the cab driver and
here's what he has to say no it
definitely doesn't come off as
down-to-earth I should say but I don't
think she really cares too much about
appearing down-to-earth Halle thanks for
joining us and we're looking forward to
next Wednesday's edition of the fake
news Awards